all right good evening good afternoon
everybody
uh depending on where you are we are
standing by
for a donald trump rally in moon
township
pennsylvania and i have a lot of
important things to discuss with you in
the time that we have
uh before this starts this is i believe
running on time it is very close to
washington dc my understanding is that
donald trump left washington dc
more than 30 minutes ago so hopefully
things will
sort of hold together right side
broadcasting is currently live we are
standing by for a fox
news now stream as well as from the
official trump
page if you know of anybody who's
currently live at the rally
other than right side broadcasting
please let me know and i will um switch
to that
i think that that would be a beautiful
thing to do
but we are indeed standing by for donald
trump now
i have to go right into
everything uh that is surrounding
the supreme court okay um
i think that we have to start coming to
terms with the reality
that republicans probably have the votes
they need
to replace ruth bader ginsburg yes
they're going to replace her
with an absolute lunatic right winger
almost literally almost not actually but
almost
literally out of a handmaid's tale okay
i'll be talking about her
amy coney barrett tomorrow
we have to come to terms with the
reality that
willard mitt romney who some speculated
maybe maybe would say we've got to be
consistent he's not going to do it
he as of now seems to be ready and
willing to vote whoever in whenever
we need to come to terms with the
reality that other
than lisa murkowski and susan collins
republican senators from alaska and
maine respectively
they're ready to go and uh what
ultimately you know there there's
nothing more frustrating
when something terrible happens than to
say we can't do
[ __ ] but let's learn let's learn
from it let's learn from it because i
was out there screaming this is not an i
told you so moment a lot of people were
doing it
i was out there screaming in 2015 and
2016 when you had
right wing and left-wing clowns
you understand you understand right
left-wing and right-wing clowns saying
these are both centrist hillary and and
trump
you know 30 000 emails
you know stuff like this it does the
supreme court who cares
who cares hillary would pick roughly the
same people as trump right you guys
remember that stuff
you remember that there were even people
on the left saying that stuff
that's done okay so when i say it's a
learning experience
i'm not saying some vague crap about
we learned we learned no no no no this
was
ex exactly exactly the scenario right
you understand that i was talking about
and now donald trump is going to get
his third pick and we will have not
four years of trump destruction maybe
eight
decades okay so um
what do you want me to say what do you
want me to say we have to come to this
reality and all we can do now
if after all this we lose in november
i mean it's sayonara right it's uh it's
it's over my friends
and uh you will never hear from me again
no i'm kidding i'm not donald trump but
in all seriousness
um it's if we if after all this we lose
now
the polls still look okay for biden okay
maybe the polls are wrong we'll see
um 100 000 i'm sorry 100 million dollars
in donations for democrats in the 48
hours following the passing of ruth
bader ginsburg
there are some things to look at but we
have to come to the
uh understanding that it doesn't seem we
can do anything to stop
donald trump from replacing ruth bader
ginsburg
after benefiting from mitch mcconnell
laughably
and hysterically blocking the nomination
by um by barack obama of merrick
garland all right so that is that
um by the way people in the chat who
just say
david what what what do you want me to
do with that there's nothing i can do
there uh there's nothing i can do with
that
uh okay people asking if this has been
rescheduled to 8 pm
i don't believe so donald trump left the
white house a while ago
it's still scheduled for 7 p.m eastern
as far as i can see i know that the
what's funny is the trump page
says live at eight but yet on the screen
it actually says 7 pm which is the
correct schedule as far as
as far as we know again does anybody
have any
other stream that might be live
right now other than this right side
broadcasting i would love to switch to
something else this right side
broadcasting is just so toxic but
i'm not finding anybody else that's live
right now
let's see and i have much more to talk
about by the way so i don't worry this
is just a brief
detour um oh my video and audio have
been off this entire time oh my god how
embarrassing
um no but seriously do we know if
anybody else is live right now
this is the opportunity to tell me uh oh
we have the fox new oh fox news hold on
i've i'm gonna add a fourth stream to my
repertoire here just so we'll be
sometimes the audio on some of these
streams is completely toxic
so it's good to have options
um okay this this may
this may be all we've got okay all right
very good
okay let me read some super chats i'm
going to thank new members moment
momentarily we are back
over a thousand subs on twitch i would
like to get to 2 000 this month quite
frankly
okay let's see what we've got for super
chats here john howell says if the
supreme court goes six to three
oh here we go very nice if the supreme
court goes six to three
then overturns roe will they interpret
the decision as a states rights issue
foreshadowing a migration to where it's
sane not on fire flooded or controlled
slow sapiens
john i don't know what on earth you're
talking about
but i am going to address on friday
um the possibility of roe v wade being
overturned
very important issue and i will address
that on friday
okay stephen says diabetic and obese
patients are an extreme waste of health
resources and their conditions are
mostly preventable
should they pay higher premiums i don't
believe so and i've addressed that in
the past
um john howell says dudley boycott by
don 2020. okay john i love the support i
am having trouble parsing some of these
um messages but that's okay
david sealy says it's disgusting that
senators pledge to vote for trump's
nominee before it's even announced just
based on party shouldn't it be based on
person well
in all in in not that i'm here to defend
these these immoral republicans
but what they've said is they want to
vote on the nominee
not they would necessarily vote to
confirm them you're right
uh if they said i will vote to confirm
trump's pick
that would be even even more immoral but
all they've said so far is they have no
problem with the timing of it
okay so let's clarify danny says please
remind people that if you receive a
ballot in the mail
and decide to vote in person you should
take the absentee one in with you
so it can be voided so no one can vote
twice my minnesota vote has been cast
beautiful message danny of peace and
love i appreciate that
uh thanks to margo cabot
for subscribing for seven months uh with
twitch
i appreciate that a beautiful evening as
you can see
for a twitch sub for a super chat
for a join pacman.com membership
um oh are people saying that there's
something not working with the
membership code that would be horrible
let me test it myself
uh sign up coupon code 2020 now let me
test it my friends
20 20 now 20 20 now
it would be so embarrassing if it
weren't working nope it's working
perfectly just user error
yep it's it's a sociopathic immoral
discount but it does work thanks to jeff
and boston
for gifting five subscriptions
on twitch um a cup oh am i going to list
my full
library okay so i i get this question
very often people see me
uh as i posted to instagram
uh where is that by the way as i posted
to instagram during my vacation people
see me reading and i often get a message
from people saying
david will you post your full library so
we can see what you're reading
now as many of you know i have a page on
my website
uh with some of the specific books i've
recommended on the show
the reason to be totally honest and this
you're gonna think i'm crazy but if you
saw my email every day you would
understand
the reason i've not put together a sort
of my bookshelf
my library page with everything i have
in my library
the reason i've not done it is there are
unfortunately people in my audience who
don't understand the difference between
reading a book and endorsing it
as as like i believe this stuff and
you know sometimes i'll do a youtube
clip and i'll say hey guys
i'm going to explain to you the argument
for something that i don't support like
i'll say
here's an example i am going to
explain to you why someone would support
trickle-down economics
i don't think these are good arguments
and people write to me and they say
david
you don't have to give these disclaimers
if i don't
i get 100 emails from people saying how
dare you
how dare you support trickle-down
economics
so this is why i issue
the disclaimers and much the same way
i know that if i list some of the books
that are on my bookshelf people will
write in and say
how dare you recommend some of this
right wing
drivel these screeds how dare you
endorse these views
and it's like hey you know you can read
something to be informed
without believing it anyway
that's actually why i um
have not just published my full library
it's it's you should see what my email
looks like it's uh it's outrageous
thanks to jimmy big nuts for the
subscription
jimmy 10 pins for the subscription
squalor goblin sally annette a lot of
beautiful people
are signing up and it's an amazing
amazing thing
super chats oh hold on did i have
anything else on my agenda book list
okay we i did book list we talked about
supreme court
um oh i'm getting people who are
starting to ask about
like once trump if trump loses in
november what will i stream what
will i will i quit streaming or what
will i stream because the trump-related
streams do well and all of this stuff
we'll see you know i mean the the the if
trump first let's see if trump loses
the transition period will be crazy if
trump loses
after the inauguration i think they'll
there will remain
interest in politics in general and
there will be biden events and other
events
but my guess is that if biden uh
if if democrats extend or maintain their
control of the house and biden wins
and in particular in particular if
um democrats take the senate
you are going to see republican
obstruction go crazy i think there will
be
republican events to cover there's going
to be all sorts of stuff to cover that's
my prediction that's my prediction i
don't think the news will stop
things will be calm or things will be a
little more rational and normal but
i think we will we will have plenty
plenty to discuss thanks to mine host
who has subscribed with twitch prime
from
ireland and napa
skip dog for subscribing with prime i
appreciate that
also a big thank you to brian vitalo
who has subscribed on my website my
website is the
best place to subscribe joinpakman.com
new member number one let's see if
anybody else is live yet
um whoa i have to listen
look at without audio this is nuts like
every aspect of what's on your screen
right now is nuts
let's just listen to a few seconds of
this in wisconsin
six days after the election
in michigan two weeks after the election
it's
it's classic democrat party stuff you
can't win
so you have to cheat and you have to
scream you have to cry
oh my god yeah so that'll that'll cause
any number of really really bad
medical conditions so you don't want to
watch that stuff okay
other super chats coming in zesty
african
says republicans are clearly being fair
about the supreme court
this is all if you look from the
standpoint of ted cruz being an alpha
male hey pat producer pat mentioned on
the bonus show today that there is a
hurricane
beta that's coming in because we've
apparently gone through
the names and so now we're on a greek
letters and that there's a hurricane
beta if you can imagine that's wild
stuff
thanks to quiggins prodigy for gifting
five more subscriptions hardwood
says david don't you see the hypocrisy
of the right
when they accuse the left of being
communists and they are supporting
a despot who is seeking a third term and
you
excuse me uh choke there and usurping
democracy at every corner
yes of course they are hypocritical but
no
there's no punishment for hypocrisy
anymore in politics
so what does it matter what does it
matter yeah they're hypocritical
tools but what it doesn't they're not
being hurt by it in any way
oliver wilde says what happens if
trump's nomination does not make it
through the senate and biden wins
by the way loved the spanish interview
you did
if trump's nomination doesn't make it
through the senate it doesn't make it
through the senate
and then if biden wins biden gets to
choose
i mean i think it's i think it's that
simple unless i'm misunderstanding the
question to some degree
jacob ratner says congrats on 1 million
subscribers have you or do you plan to
read the bob woodward book
no you know here's the thing i have
speaking of books i have so many books
uh ready ready to read right now i'm
reading a random walk down wall street
a 1973 classic updated in 2020 the
author of the book is now 88 years old
absolutely fantastic book i just
finished reading
um a brief history of everyone who ever
lived
tremendous book tremendous book i have
so much stuff to read
that i tend not to read any political
stuff it's like i've got enough
i've got enough uh politics uh in in my
job
so i tend not to read any anything like
that
and i tend to go for summaries you know
blinkist is very good
with quick summaries of a lot of these
books they're a sponsor in full
disclosure so that's uh that's my
tendency to be perfectly honest with you
by the way speaking of a million
i am ready to present i have no fresh
memes for you guys today
but i have a meme request we have a
possible
explosive new meme format thanks to
receiving 1 million
youtube subscribers youtube sent me a
red velvet cake for 30 people
sorry i glitched there it was such a
crazy thing to say that i glitched
um here is the cake okay this is an
incredible cake i posted this to my
twitter today
i posted it to instagram yesterday all
right this is a meme alert ladies and
gentlemen
meme alert congrats on 1 million
subscribers
this could be an explosive new meme
format so take it do what you want some
ideas that could be funny
obviously so here so like it's obvious
to yeah 30 guys this cake is like a foot
tall
it's it's an it's a foot deep how much
are you going to have you're going to
have what a half inch by a foot
half inch wide piece we're talking about
30 people here
here's some ideas changing what's on the
cake
could be funny replacing my face
okay could be funny if done nicely
changing
the painting in the background including
a sort of mount rushmore replacing those
five faces with other faces
i think that that could also be pretty
funny so there's a lot of potential here
please please please if you do generate
some some memes from this send them to
me
image your links via the contact form at
join pac
at davidpakman.com are probably the best
way to get it to me
okay so please and i'm by the way these
are not
forced we're not forcibly memeing here
i'm merely suggesting
forced memes would be very much against
everything i stand for but uh
voluntary memes would be really really
great
okay i wanna say thanks to tamara
reitman
who is new member number two today at
joinpackman.com
we have a plane leaving ladies and
gentlemen looks like a delta m
is that what it what is that a uh
embraer
uh is that an e190 maybe
by the way it doesn't bode well that a
plane is leaving because usually there's
a flight restriction for a while before
trump lands
so that does not bode super well
but maybe they're being a little bit
less uh
strict about that i don't know
okay yeah all right crj yeah very nice
um okay let's uh let's keep going with
the oh people are masking up so that
suggests trump is close to landing
okay um super chats continue to come in
listen if you want to get in touch and
put your message up on the screen
super chats are the perfect way to do it
lou bid up says pacman you need to stop
wearing t-shirts
at work it's not a flattering look when
you got bean sprout
arms are you allergic to protein fella
hashtag friceps i genuinely feel sorry
for you
i uh oh are people are we landing here
uh cars are racing down the runway um i
genuinely feel sorry for you that in
these uh tragic times
you are sending super chats about that
but i hope it was worth the five dollars
um let's see what else we've got
steven robbins also known as ronald
raygun says
pack up d-man it's ray gun tomorrow is
my birthday can you send me a piece of
that cake
you know by the time it got to you it
would be very stale
unfortunately unknown prodigy says i
refuse to believe
a ginsburg oh there's a kid with a full
face shield being very careful i like
that
i refuse to believe an rbg replacement
will be pushed through
some republicans with morals will stop
it it will backfire horribly
prodigy i hope you're right i hope you
are right
um
[Music]
thanks to matthew fanning for
signing up at joinpackman.com you are
new member number
three as we await the arrival of donald
trump
in uh moon township pennsylvania
i believe it's called kumar says right
now
i can see democrats getting 49 seats
georgia is key to flip the senate as a
georgia guy i don't know if that will
happen
we've got to fight every fight that's
that's all we can do we'll do an
assessment
of the um we'll do an assessment of the
senate
soon very very soon sinful solution
says can we get some lo-fi plasma
yeah i guess we could uh i guess we
could do a little plasma
let me see if i can find it uh sound oh
it's on soundcloud is the problem
let me see here this
is um this is a masterpiece by the way
by joe woodward
if you haven't heard this this is the
plasma song make a truly historic
announcement in our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
this is the song that's going to get me
through quarantine number two
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
[Music]
announcement in our battle against the
china virus that will
save countless lives we provided 48
million dollars to fund the mayo clinic
study that tested the
efficacy of anyway so that i keep that
on gary page one in pink i love the
howard stern reference there in uh in
twitch chat
very very nice uh all right welcome if
you're just joining us so we are
we have just passed the stroke of 7pm
i never really understood what that
meant but we it's definitely happened
here on the east coast
4 p.m on the west uh we believe
that donald trump is very close to
landing as a
very very sad attempt at the wave gets
going here as you can see
very few masks anywhere that will be off
camera once trump starts speaking as all
of you can see
and this is officially a corona rally as
we have dubbed them
um but yeah we are expecting donald
trump landing
very very soon um
and it is of course 6 p.m central time
yes i apologize for forgetting about
central time and i might as well mention
it's it's 5 p.m mountain time
if we're going to do it we're going to
do it and we're going to do it right
okay other super chats that continue to
pour in
steve parmee says isn't it time then to
load
the supreme court isn't it finally time
for the democrats to find a bit of
courage
and fight fire with fire it may be and
it could dramatically backfire and we're
gonna cover that on the friday show
actually
uh could it could very very powerfully
backfire
chris says why amy m
ran to unseat meet mitch that was
a bad pick uh the people voted for her
she won the primary so that's how we
select uh that's how we select
candidates
tim carlson says do you believe that god
and religion is a problem are you a
believer
i am not religious myself i am uh
you you probably will never meet anybody
uh
more jewish than me from the standpoint
of cuisine
i am culturally jewish i am ethnically
jewish at the right
zoom level people who read adam
rutherford's book on
on genetics will understand what i mean
um
but i am not a believer i believe that
uh religion
can certainly be innocuous if it is just
you know a private matter that doesn't
inform
um public policy for example and
you know great go go for it but i do
believe
particularly you know i can speak to the
united states the religious right
is a major major major problem
which is the best religion that's a good
question i think it's probably
come on guys give me a break dustin says
spare some hope for the needy seriously
though that sinking feeling
yeah you you know we're all we're all in
it together
thanks roon for the youtube membership
chakaseki says can't wait to watch el
presidente's good brain melt into a
lurid and loathsome lake of liquid limb
burger
stanky love the alliteration
love the alert it's going to be a
disgusting depraved and delusional rally
i'm sorry get ready for depraved
delusional
diabolical and disgusting diatribes
from donald trump okay i guess i'm out
there
matt chavez says the people at this
rally would likely support removing
arabic numerals from being taught in u.s
schools that's how clueless and
xenophobic they are yeah you could
probably trick people with that i'm sure
um i see claims being made
that stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell ii has been banned in my
twitch chat that is not true to the best
of my knowledge
if he has been banned i do want to hear
from the moderator that banned him
uh please email me but to my knowledge
uh destiny has not been banned i think
it's just a joke
i do want to say thank you to paul
getzel paul is new member number four
today
at joinpacman.com let me make a number
of declarations
to the twitch audience i want to thank
fat zangief for subscribing with twitch
prime
oh i guess that's the only declaration
that's sad i thought i was going to have
more uh
more declarations to make but that is
the only one
okay um
where are we on subscribers oh yeah oh
so
there's this interesting thing let me
see if i can show you this
uh you might some people might find this
interesting
some people might find this completely
uninteresting
let me see if i can find it i'm gonna
pull up the social blade page
for our youtube channel if you look at
subscribers
okay see what happens once we got to a
million subscribers which was on 9
12 we're just at a million every day
and i'm getting a lot of emails from
people saying david
is it over are you no longer
gaining subscribers what happens is that
a few months ago
youtube updated where
only the first three digits of
subscriber numbers are visible
so it was 992 997
999 to quote the great ben feingold
when we get to one it now will only
update
every 10 000 subscribers why
because that would be 1.01
thousand uh 1.01 million 1.02 million so
we actually
we are actually at 1 million nine
thousand subscribers right now and
that means actually we've got six
thousand people watching right now
on on youtube if we can get a thousand
more subscribers during the stream
we will see this roll over to 1.01
million
i think everybody understands or doesn't
care
so i can uh i can move on from that
c lee m town says via twitch
prime david did you see when trump was
giving out his autograph
saying sell it for ten thousand and do
you see that as him literally trying to
buy votes even if his autograph is
worthless in his mind he's handing
people ten grand i'd like to know what
you think
yeah it was delusional for two reasons
it was delusional because donald trump
thinks his autograph on a random scrap
of paper is worth 10 grand
that's delusional and it's also
delusional in that this is how donald
trump thinks to relate to people
it's all crazy it's it's absolutely and
completely outrageous
um and i think it's uh it's part of the
same narcissism
and disregard for uh for the rules that
we've seen from trump
uh from day one quite frankly
um okay people calling me delusional in
the chat
is that bandworthy i don't think so like
i don't really care about that
i don't i don't really have a pr you
know if that's how you want to spend
your time that's okay
um okay ashley ramer says i think belief
in god or not has
zero relevance to the conversation we
are supposed to be a secular society
exactly right
as long as you keep the religion out of
any kind of
policy um then believe whatever you want
at home right i mean it's like i don't
think it's right to believe in flat
earth
i think it's whacked but if you believe
it at home and somehow it doesn't infect
every aspect of your life then
i guess it's relatively innocuous you
know when you get into anti-vaxx it's no
longer innocuous right anti-vaxx
actually affects uh
affects the world uh in a broader way
yeah i think that's fair
donna williams says because trump has
been the most corrupt president ever
don't you think he should be held
accountable
you know donna i do i do think trump
should be held accountable
ashley ramer says separation of church
and state my friends
well said well said val mcclinchy says
will you take live calls i haven't
called in since forever
i i think the next live calls are
probably val
going to be um a week from today
after the the debate if we have a very
powerful
evening we're hoping for our best stream
ever
it's going to be up tough but we're
we're hoping for our best stream ever
next
tuesday for the joe biden versus donald
trump debate
and we may indeed blow open the phone
lines it could get really crazy
all right let's see here um
d-pat says if pot is decriminalized
federally
can states still make it illegal and
charge you i don't believe
so i don't believe so
um let's see we have the camera rotating
and going back to the stairs there is
commotion so you would imagine
we are getting very very close to the
landing of donald trump's plane
a force says i bought alpha on youtube
how do i get the bonus show
you know unfortunately youtube still has
not enabled
that function so we are ready to
uh offer it but unfortunately it has not
yet been enabled so right now to get the
bonus show you do have to sign up either
on my website or on patreon some some
call it patreon i call it patreon
let's see here pookie says
oh my god put up a portrait of trump in
all red
with h and s i have no idea what that
means
i have no clue whatsoever what that
means
um super chats continue to come in i
would encourage you to send one
that's just my take ant and sharon
say hey david congrats on a million the
bottom the gift of desperation is my
upcoming biography i'd love to gift one
love the super pac vid super pac
i don't know what that's about uh carpe
donnelly says
please meme jeb pakman yeah yeah yeah i
know
when i called for memes of this picture
it was my jeb bush please clap moment
please meme please meme i love it
uh okay everybody's holding their phones
in the air
so we can only assume that donald trump
is about to land
do you guys predict the big plane or the
small plane today what do you think what
do people believe
i'm predicting the small plane um
and i think it's because i see the small
stairs to be perfectly frank
oh a lot of people predicting the big
plane
interesting interesting
uh well we will soon see it we will soon
see it
yeah people very excited about it very
very excited
oh hold on is that the plane landing
there it is
it is the oh my god i lost
it's the big plane i lost i lost hugely
well how embarrassing oh my god
what i probably should end the show that
is so embarrassing
okay as we wait for donald trump to pull
up
uh caroline says i love your show i i do
appreciate everybody who's signing up um
jess wargo is new member number five
today at joinpakman.com
stephen hart says do you think the cindy
mccain endorsement will help joe biden
in any significant way
i didn't see that she endorsed him let
me uh let me look at that first and then
i'll
respond c says if dems take the senate
how likely do you think it is that they
will actually end the filibuster and add
new judges honestly i think it's like 15
i think it's about a 15 shot
um oliver wilde says sorry for the
poorly phrased
chat i'm wondering is what i'm wondering
is if trump's first nomination is shot
down
can he rapid fire nominate others before
biden takes office to see if one of the
choices sticks
he absolutely could my instinct
is that yes they can squeeze through one
confirmation
if trump's first pick fails i just don't
know particularly if biden loses
if republican republicans will have an
appetite for that i don't know the
answer
we're going to have to wait and see
ashley ramer says i feel that whatever
it is that guides your morality is less
relevant than the direction of your
purpose
okay um
gabriel carby says when do you do
collins i'm selfish and i've got a
million questions we will next take
take calls for the for the podcast
tomorrow
at noon 15 eastern time
okay noon 15 eastern time tomorrow
um all right stephen does stuff says
what's your favorite book on economics
oh i couldn't there are just so many i
mean
i've read everything from you know angus
deaton's books
to thomas sowell for a more traditional
center right perspective
to there's just so much economic
literature
that um i couldn't possibly i would
actually say check out davidpakman.com
recommendations there's a bunch of
recommendations there
i actually have on my bookshelf now i
think it's called
is it good economics for hard times
yeah good economics for hard times i
believe that that's a that's those are
nobel
uh prize winners um
yeah that i've got that one haven't read
it yet but i've been told that it is
very very good thanks to matt miller for
subscribing at joinpackman.com matt
miller is
new member number six today at
joinpacman.com i appreciate that
uh i'm not going to fall for this
let me just say nicholas gurz
dave i don't think you have bean sprout
arms but i follow you on instagram and
there are earthworms with more girth
than your legs
no you know if there's one thing uh i
i've got the uh i've got the soccer
quads i am argentinian it's genetic
i'm kidding by the way i'm not an idiot
but um no my my legs are
my legs are fine believe me believe me
people who follow me on
only fans would know that that's a joke
i only have a cameo not a uh not an only
fans
jsh capital says reps are horrible
republicans are horrible
but how much blame should pelotzi
schumer and obama shoulder for having us
in this mess why are dems always on the
losing side
you'd have to be more specific you'd
have to be more specific about that
um okay alejandro sanchez says on the
topic of religion remember kenneth
copeland blowing kovad19 away
by the way love the show yeah kenneth
copeland he that's
that guy's a piece of work john henley
asks where this event is taking place i
believe it is
moon township moon township
pennsylvania pennsylvania
uh the crowd very wound up let's see
what's playing
and he's quick
[Music]
billy joel would be disgusted billy joel
would be
disgusted at hearing that
i can tell you that for a fact my
friends
absolutely vile absolutely vile
uh john howell says secular humanist is
your vibe david yeah i've got a lot of
secular humanist
going in my philosophy double double d
beats says david i would want to know
about making voting
a mandatory obligation voting percentage
is so low
excuse my english i'm french canadian i
have segments on my youtube channel
about the idea of compulsory voting i am
from a country argentina
that actually has compulsory voting and
um
i have i have clips about that which i
would encourage you to check out
uh oh oh my god we have a shot fired
across the bow i already have a cake
meme
here is the one i put up here is one
that was sent to me
a shot across the bow wow look at that
that is something that is something a
majority report
cake has been sent to me that is crazy
let me see if i got any others
uh nope that's the only the only cake
meme that i have so far
okay they are pulling up the stairs
for donald trump um
you know what what made me guess that it
was the small plane today
is that normally they have two sets of
stairs for the 747.
maybe they're maybe this is like a real
quick rally and it's just trump getting
off the front and that's it
you know i'm just not sure uh
but we will we will very very soon see
donald trump
did i miss some did i say something
funny without even recognizing it
there's people going crazy in the chat
i don't know g egan says tragic that a
percentage of people at this rally
will die of covid as a direct result
of attending said rally that's it's more
than uh
yeah it's it's more than tragic i don't
know what would be it's cataclysmic
cataclysmic um always trump gonna be
driven
is the limo showing up because trump's
gonna not gonna walk over
isn't it just a few feet this is weird
very odd okay but i guess trump's taking
the car
space chase says ebay signed trump hat
200
yeah if a signed hat is going for 200 i
don't think that a signed scrap of paper
is going for uh for for 10 grand that's
for sure
uh people imagine being this excited
to hear donald trump speak during a
pandemic
that you would wait this long and be
crowded together with no masks no social
distancing
it is uh it's tragic that you know
there's
millions of these people in this country
thanks to penny bluebell for subscribing
on twitch at tier one thanks to mommy
chickson
for gifting a tier one community
subscription
uh how many tier three subscribers do i
have on twitch
it's very few i think it's six
right now i think of the 1027
it is only uh i think it's only six tier
three subscribers
all right we are very close to the start
of this rally all sorts of people
gathering around
air force one i do want to make a very
very brief
pitch now what i'm what i'm about to
tell you is
uh that this is a completely sociopathic
deal that i'm about to tell you uh you
can you can obtain
but i am going to do it just bear that
in mind that this is really crazy crazy
stuff i would love it if you grabbed a
membership on my website at
joinedpakman.com and when i mean i would
love it i mean that i would really
respect you and i would find it
humbling if you did that we have all
these different revenue sources why
because i think it's important to
diversify but
we don't control any of them other than
website memberships
okay so youtube can
and has cut us off twitch crazy things
can happen on twitch
facebook facebook we don't even have a
contact at facebook sometimes
we'll go a week making zero with
facebook monetization we never know why
there's nobody to call there's nobody to
contact there's nobody to talk to
okay website memberships are our primary
funding source
i would love it if you got one it's
really cheap
it's really easy you need very limited
technical knowledge to be able to get a
membership
and as people sign up this bar starts to
fill up
with bright blue okay i would love to
get to 25.
we've gotten to 50. sometimes we'll get
to 75
once we got to 100 during a stream okay
and
if you look at the prices and you say oh
my god these prices are
disgustingly high if that's your
reaction
use the coupon code use the coupon code
2020 now
saves you 66 percent drops it to two
bucks a month
or a dollar eighty if you pay for the
year and i will thank everybody okay so
in all seriousness i would love to uh i
would love to see
you um on my screen
ken holly is new member number seven
today
that's a crooked number that we like ken
holly thank you i appreciate it
um and of course in all seriousness
listen sign up anywhere
patreon it's september over on twitch we
love that
but we do have full control over those
website memberships and i would love to
see you there i would really love to see
you there
plan r says trump rally aka
super power in decline daily [ __ ] show
right right
um other super chats coming in
i missed a bunch of them uh
hold on a second where is that okay here
we go
the dude says greed in religion has been
the main cause of most problems we face
as a species both man-made go figure
some divergent views in the audience
chaka seki says i believe
in the only true god nyarlathotep
and his father as a thoth
i am hoping a candidate will finally
represent my religious beliefs in
congress
i would uh i would not hold my breath
solange gregory says i bought
memberships on youtube and your site
give me a shout out
thank you solange i appreciate that i
really do
luke trefry says vaush bad
vaush bad i don't know what the hell
that means i hope it's not racist
i don't know what i just said pookie
says i was referencing the cake meme
put trump up oh that's not yeah that's
not a bad idea
i guess trump could be introduced into
this meme
in some different ways sure i could see
that i could see that very strongly
scott phantasm says hey david congrats
on 1 million using this
super chat to shout out my ep faces of
dismay
that is one year old today all right
lindsay petty says does this area
does this area have very low cases the
way they are all on top of each other
not particularly no it's just uh you
know trump's holding rallies as if there
is no coronavirus
that's all no big deal right
michelle royce forgives me for what i
don't know but thank you michelle
zachary foster says friend in europe
saying covid fatigue is even worse in
france in her estimation versus the u.s
ironic ironically enough that said i was
thinking of escaping to france for three
months
in uh early 2021 if things did not go
well
you understand but um i'm going to have
to potentially reconsider
jeez guido
slapnuts says what are the chances trump
is connected to epstein how likely will
he be legally connected to the case
legally unlikely is he connected of
course
of course he has been on uh his plane
and uh or has he he's been at his at his
uh at his penthouse apartment in new
york
plain maybe is not right i thought he
was but maybe that's wrong i don't want
to i want to be careful with that
um okay what else do we have
oh that's an aggressive message stephen
i'm not going to read that because there
are kids who watch so i'm not going to
read that one
that's pretty aggressive samuel says i
became a member on joinpakman.com thank
you i see
the memberships are explosive right now
i'm going to list
a few people and we'll keep doing it
while trump speaks
is new member number eight rachel nelson
is number nine
maxwell sweet is number 10. ankit
bambani
is number 11. ken berger is number 12
julia frank is number 13. connor
macarthur is number 14
miles k 15. ryan bland's
is number 16. i appreciate that the
website
working beautifully my friends take
advantage take advantage
we may run out of memberships it's
conceivable we could actually run out
the
the discount is so powerful we could run
out of memberships if you can imagine
that
gabriel carby says hey should read i'm
swedish not i'm selfish
okay very nice i love it
laughing man says can the supreme court
rule on presidential term limits
um no i don't think so that's that's
uh i don't believe so
i don't believe so sean brass
says trump could be facing criminal tax
investigation according to the manhattan
d.a
in new court filing will this matter it
will not matter in terms of the election
it will not matter in terms of the
election no
uh okay guys listen we have two very uh
oh my phone is blowing up
oh okay no everything's okay we have two
very important milestones that we could
reach
right now okay if 700 of the 8 000
youtube viewers
subscribe to my channel right now we
will get to 1 million
10 000 subscribers we're at 1 million
right now
okay 1 million 10 000 let's do it and
if only three hundred people follow me
on twitch
we will get to fifty thousand fifty
thousand
is a very important milestone as soon as
we get to fifty thousand
the official campaign for 100k begins
okay i'm talking to you guys people on
twitch
does david c twitch chat do i see it
i'm talking to you right now okay uh we
are only 300 and what is that 332
from uh 50 000 on twitch an incredible
number a powerful number
here is donald trump we are going to
hear from him very very soon
uh it looks like has donald trump
decided to walk over
yeah it seems like he realized it
wouldn't be a good idea to take a car
for
a hundred feet
across the plains of texas ah they're
still doing the thing where
who is this guy right here is that a
secret that can't be a secret service
agent right who who is
i don't know who it is okay
um i see the memberships coming in
don't worry when trump starts speaking
i'm going to get us an accurate count
i'm going to get us a very very accurate
count story guy says wrong plane eat the
whole cake solo
i don't know what that means why is it
trump plays progressive artist music
in his rallies no i is there really that
much conservative music unless you want
country
lance smith says our friend matt
dillahunty has a call-in show and is
allowed
to talk about politics i don't know what
allowed means
what does allow who was not allowing
matt to talk about politics i was just
emailing actually
with uh matt dillahunty um
just a few days ago guys something about
these guys on screen is weirding me out
the two guys on the left and the guy to
the far right
what's up with their arms
very very odd stuff
look at this guy on the right what's up
with his arms
actually this guy's entire proportions
are odd but that's okay
that's okay
man this is not these are not the people
i go to if i need help with anything
anything i can't think of anything i go
to these guys for help with
yeah uh yeah it's starting soon guys
it's obviously it's starting very soon
as you can tell
says curious why election day is not a
national holiday so people can go vote
and not worry about work thank you very
much for the shows and info
wow i like it i would love election day
as a holiday
christine wilson says if there is a god
it'll start raining all over the corona
rally
and potentially save many people's lives
in the crowd that would be great
david carroll says great show david
thank you trump is doing the fist pumps
now
do that song that i ca i cannot do that
song that is just not going to work for
me
um prince tiger beats industry kits
says david is insane that you
one of the few that can move past
this unlike jimmy dore and kyle kalinsky
who is still raging on the internet
about joe
prince i love you thank you for the
support i don't know
what you're talking to me about right
now i don't know if that was google
translate or what that was
uh but i i love the support jeremy
landry says
whoa that disappeared where did that go
uh jeremy landry watch me swoop right in
all right eileen olek says my name's
maximus
decimus meridius commander of the armies
of the north
general of the felix legions lawyers
loyal servant to the true emperor marcus
aurelius
all right sounds like an identity crisis
donald
trump says we're going to nars that's
right ladies and gentlemen
we are going to nars thanks to
[ __ ] smash who has just very powerfully
subscribed with twitch prime
with the message eight months with david
in joe biden's america well said
thanks also to revived newt and katie
freckles let's uh listen to the insanity
[Music]
my god vile
vile
buy it
[Music]
well thank you very much pittsburgh a
great place
you have always treated me well thank
you pittsburgh
i thought he was in moon township is
that a suburb or something to be back
in the commonwealth of pennsylvania
oh my god hard-working american patriots
and by the way the home of the
pittsburgh steelers congratulations
congratulations good team great
quarterback don't you think i think he's
great
big ben right big fan he's good man he's
a good man
42 days from now we're going to win
pennsylvania and we're going to win
four more years in the white house let's
hope not
and we're all entitled to it i will tell
you that
with your vote we're going to lift our
nation to
extraordinary new heights we're going to
turn the page forever on the failed
political class
and that's exactly what we've been doing
and we're going to defend our jobs our
families our boy
again acting like someone else has been
president the last four years
and remember we now put
america first we do it
it's been a long time oh okay it's been
a long time
this is the most important election in
the history of our country i believe
that
this election is a matter of economic
survival for pennsylvania
you had the greatest year you've ever
had last year and you're
really on your way uh we were very very
sadly disturbed by what happened with
china
china they let the plague out they
shouldn't have done it
but you're now on your way we closed it
up we saved millions of lives that's the
bottom line
205 000 people have died my friends he
gave himself an a plus last night on on
coronavirus i will tell you you see
what's happening you see the numbers as
well as i do
you are on your way to i think maybe
economically the best year this next
year will be the best year we've had
and the third quarter where do you look
at the third quarter look at the numbers
they will be out before the election but
i predict they'll be
very good by the way if they're not i
deny i ever said i said
i deny but i'm pretty confident they're
going to be incredible probably the best
ever under my administration
we proudly achieved energy independence
and don't forget i am not the candidate
to two candidates that said
we're not gonna have fracking we're
gonna ban fracking and he said that for
a year
love it then all of a sudden he said
well maybe we'll have some fracking
by the way you know that's not gonna
last cause the radical left won't let
him get away with it
and i'm all for so when biden says ban
fracking he believes he wants to do it
when biden says maybe we would have some
he says oh biden's lying
it's uh just a tremendous part but i was
in texas two weeks ago
and my opponent is against oil
no guns and god
biden's actually religious trump isn't
whether you like that or not but
biden's actually the religious candidate
15 sir
i said well the fake news says i'm up
four
i said he said you're not a four and i
wanted by a lot last night
remember last time with you with texas
with many states
it's too close to call we don't know and
then boom the polls close they say trump
won trump when trump won
we won a lot
and i won pennsylvania because of you i
won pennsylvania and you had your best
year so i mean that's the way it's
supposed to work
and i think we're going to win a lot
don't forget last time i came in i said
i was going to give you the tax cuts as
regulation cuts
i said we're going to do big things with
energy big things with steel
your steel mills every one of them would
have been and why hasn't he done it he's
been president for the last term why
does he now need to get reelected to do
anything
now i've done everything i said and more
i've done more i've done
more than i saw so this should be easier
and i hear we're doing really well
i know we're doing really well based on
you know we came in with a lot of you
great congressman i said how are we
doing they said you're going to win it
by a lot
but we better win it we got to go out we
got to vote
but powered by the incredible workers of
your state
you are now really if you look at it
the number one producer think of it
we are as a nation your state is you
have no idea how big an energy you know
how big you are in energy people don't
think of pennsylvania that way
do you have any do you have any idea
what and as a nation we're the biggest
in the world by far not even close and
we are
energy independent think of that
but no longer is america at the mercy of
these foreign suppliers and
all of the people that took advantage of
us for so many years we now don't have
to be in other parts of the world
we're there perhaps to help allies we're
there perhaps to help
good people but we're not there because
we need their energy because
we need their oil instead we're the
dominant energy producer we're going to
keep
at some point he'll mention by the way
we took syria's oil so if we don't need
it why are we doing that
our opponents they don't want petroleum
products okay
they want wind that's great open up wind
let's have some wind and every once in a
while imagine booing clean energy like
this
is idiotic then you can close down your
plan for the rest of the season
you can watch those birds fly out of the
sky
gee i always say it's a bird graveyard
under the windmills
that that's by the way one of the most
idiotic arguments against wind farms
you see what's happening in california
blackouts rolling blackouts
how would you like that in pennsylvania
the commonwealth of pennsylvania
you know it's so it's backwards the the
reason there's rolling back blackouts is
because things are getting so warm
everybody's having to run their acs
way more than they otherwise would if we
weren't burning so many fossil fuels
like it's come it's it's backwards
everything's backwards
we can watch your rerun now this is
what's happening you have rolling
blackouts you have
in some cases it's just blackouts i
don't even call them rolling
not going to happen to your state last
year i visited the shell
petrochemical plant in beaver county
pennsylvania
the largest investment in your state's
history
and that was all made possible by our
pro-energy policies
and we've done it a lot in louisiana
we're building something imagine
thinking your base is so stupid that you
have to frame things as being
for or against energy and then imagine
your base
actually being that stupid bobs are in
very grave peril because the radical
left maniacs they don't want to have
anything to do with energy
they don't want anything to do with uh
they they have different concepts right
uh they have the green new deal where
there will be no energy almost of any
kind
right no energy no it's it's crazy
thought of by aoc plus three you know
a.s
[Music]
not a good student not good at anything
but she's got
trump bought his way into u-pen
he's got a hell of a loan
and she's got him you know she's radical
left but she's not as bad as some of
them
how about omar of minnesota
we're going to win the state of
minnesota because of her they say
unlikely
she's telling us how to run our country
how did you do where you came from how
is your country doing they're going to
tell
she's going to tell us she's telling us
how to run our country is he saying
guntry the democrats in congress you
have to see what they're doing their
stance on israel it's like a whole
different world
it's like from 10 years ago it's like a
different world
and we want to keep our world the way it
was and the way it's going to be
we've got the greatest country on earth
and we're going to keep it that way
we don't need socialists and we don't
need communists
telling us who are the con could we name
one communist in power
[Music]
you know i do this every night and a lot
of times it's a waste i did it
last night we were did you see the crowd
we had last night
which ones were a waste we're in a great
place ohio
and we had a crowd we had a crowd you
couldn't see the end of it and i said
turn around
camera turn around but they never like
doing that you know they don't like
spinning those cameras they don't want
to show the crowd
it's actually pretty difficult to flip
these the large cameras around 180
degrees
it's it's kind of a weird request um
this
is it's an honor let me tell you
look you know i used to think there was
a difficulty like it was a new camera
that can't turn
but then whenever there was like a
problem like there'd be a little
argument or
some kind of an anti-trump person you
couldn't see that much i don't want to
bring it on but you don't see it much
anymore you know no
there's no anti-trump people left in the
country yeah but you know
i'd see the camera would never move but
ever when there's something like a
little negative happening
that thing would turn around like a
pretzel
and i said oh it does move but they
never want to show
the crowds they never last night now i
went home and i tell you this i go home
all the time
first lady how'd you like the crowd sir
i didn't see it
the first lady refers to him as sir
that's bizarre
call me mr president but she's only
kidding believe me
she's only kevin has she been a great
first lady right
hey guys it's getting a little too weird
even for me
and very popular she's really done a
great job and she works hard you know
we have some great people here tonight i
brought certain members of my family but
i'm going to introduce
them to you in a little way
oh if those dudes were trump's family
that actually explains a lot tell you
what they work hard
they really work hard but i do wish i do
wish they would show because it would be
you know it's actually better for them
if they show it shows the importance
the only thing you can do is it's true
i'll say
how did it look i don't know how it
looked but the sound was phenomenal
okay it sounded like a penn state
football game like a steelers
[Applause]
you know you can't disguise it you ever
see sleepy joe with the little circles
like
he puts him very far away it's called
being responsible
and then he comes up with the mask he's
like a hundred yards from the nearest
human being he's got a man
he feels good about the mask i wonder in
the debate
it'll be him and i on the stage is he
gonna walk in with a mask
[Applause]
why not i'll be honest he feels good
about he feels good about the mask and
that's okay you know what whatever makes
you feel good
trump's laughing at someone taking
coronavirus seriously he's actually
laughing at that leslie
what the hell did he spend all that
money on the plastic surgery if he's
going to cover it up with a bow
oh god here we go
you guys notice this tick trump has
where his right elbow goes out
with a mask i don't know you have no i
have no idea well the question is
will he leave it on during the debate
because it's a little hard
and i'm far from this when you need a
mama but when you're making a speech and
the nearest person trump's ridiculing
masks as
everybody behind him is wearing a mask
and then he had a habit of taking it off
and it hangs down on his ear
as he's speaking he feels comfort it
makes him feel comfortable
and you know honestly whatever makes you
feel good is okay with me
but it'll be interesting i'm gonna be
we're gonna have a big rating on that
and you know he's been doing it all his
life he's been doing it for 47 years and
i've just started doing this stuff
i'm so sorry
but you know i'm just thinking but i did
more
in 47 months than he did in 47 years
oh god
that long again
you look at what we've done
does he do the three-term thing guys
what do you think will he do it
no it's true that's actually true he did
a lot of negative stuff too you have to
deduct that out
when asked if there would be any place
for fossil fuels including coal
fracking in a biden administration
joe replied no we would make sure that
it's all eliminated
all of a sudden he gets the nomination
you know he's been trying to get
the nomination for so i'm sure you guys
understand how deceptive that
is joe biden's plan would put us on a
road
to 20 30 years down the line getting off
of those fossil fuels
optimistically the idea that biden would
ban that
in 2021 is ridiculous but again if your
followers will believe it why not tell
the story
left socialism perhaps communism i don't
know
perhaps it's verging on communism right
but had she been loyal she would have
left she would have quit she had no
chance she was out pocahontas she was
gone
remember i said i have more indian blood
in me than you have and i have none
and i'd love to have some but i don't
happen to have any
and then she choked and she went out and
got a test and she announced you had
1 000 24th right 1 000.
that means like i said it last night
that means around 700 or eight hundred
years ago somewhere there was a little
bit of a relationship going that's okay
seven eight hundred years ago maybe what
a phony she is huh isn't she terrible
what on earth and now we're gonna pick a
great woman
any one of the five that i told you but
any one of the women that we had they're
all great
people great scholars great brilliant
people
a lot of people
no they're all great women they're
brilliant great scholars by the way
while i'm here
would anybody prefer that i pick a man
[Applause]
is there any man that has the courage to
raise
this routine again there's one right
there
i got one we found one no we're gonna
pick an incredible woman brilliant woman
and watch
the abuse that she will take whoever
it's gonna the decision's gonna be
announced on saturday
five o'clock on saturday at the white
house
and you see we have tremendous
republican support
two people you know always got to be
two always gotta be the two
those two okay we have great support
from the republican party tremendous
support it's never been this unified
before ever
never in the fake impeachment we had 196
to nothing republican support
and we had 52 and a half to a half in
the senate who was the half i can't
imagine
i can't but he was very good today i
have to tell you it was good
now i'm happy thank
very positive statement but days ago
biden reiterated his pledge to require
net zero carbon emissions that's
basically saying you know
by what year there will be no more oil
there'll be no more gas
by one year i think there'll be no more
industry there'll be no more country
that's what it's like really
and that would instantly shut down all
fracking and all mining immediately in
pennsylvania
sending your jobs overseas sending your
money to somebody else not you
and i'll keep you jobs in pennsylvania
where they belong and you're going to be
doing fracking for a long time
again cheering for fracking guys in 2020
it's like being proud of being
idiotic gee and i can say the same thing
to you as i say in texas
so they don't want oil they don't want
fracking
right they don't want the energy that we
know that powers these massive plants
because the other stuff is wonderful
it's not going to do it it's not going
to do it
so they don't like oil they don't like a
gas
i guess they don't like god religion
the churches are closed remember biden's
religious and trump isn't
still have uh churches and by the way
your governor hasn't been so great you
know
[Applause]
are your churches still closed there's
still clouds
they're doing it for a reason by the way
november 4th they'll announce we've
decided to open up okay
wrong they're trying to make our numbers
as bad as possible
so california is close pennsylvania's
close north carolina's clubs
michigan is closed trump seems not to
understand that
it's mostly the churches who are saying
we're going to do services outside or
whatever he went to north carolina he
said the state's got to open
state's basically open it's just
nobody's going to the businesses because
people want to be safe some people
anyway
watch it and the authorities are
watching but please report it
but when you look at it really it's
amazing and they're trying to make our
numbers look bad
but even with numerous closed states and
you notice
also law and order right law yep the red
states
the republican states they're working
great
record low crime record low
but democrat run states
you look at chicago you look at new york
new york has gone through
we have to bring back we should draft
rudy giuliani okay
i'm not even going to address this here
but check out my video clip
from the last couple of weeks about
violence in supposedly democratic-run
cities
i tell you rudy is amazing but he did a
great job
new york was in big trouble he came in
and he he just was tough
smart and it became the safest big city
and now we have a man where
some categories of crime were up 300
percent
he fired a thousand he fired a lot of
police
i guess a billion dollars a year worth
of
police worth of great police firemen
i'm gonna put up on the screen an
amazing meme cody sent me
uh but we're gonna keep listening to
trump see what's happening to new york
we're going to make a little bit of a
play for new york you know in theory
they automatically the democrats
automatically win new york
but i do phenomenally in most parts and
then one part
uh it's automatic man but i can't
imagine that particular part is going to
be very happy so we're going to make a
play
for new york man that's good
with pennsylvania i don't have to make a
play we've got pennsylvania that's
really good
we don't have to it's a great you know
for years though pennsylvania was a
place that
republicans just didn't win and for many
years everybody thought they were going
to win
every republican said yeah we're going
to win pennsylvania they thought they
were going to win it and they didn't and
i came along
and we won it and we won it quite easily
quite easily
and i think we're going to do even
better now because remember number one
in the history of your state last year
and that's because of what we did
we stopped the dumping we saved your
steel so many different things but
pennsylvania is the home of american
energy think of it that way and this has
taken place over a very short period of
time also the birthplace
of a thing called the american
constitution right
american constitution
and to uphold our constitution as
written
as opposed to as sometimes i like to
look at who's behind trump and see like
who's the wackiest who's behaving in the
most bizarre way
this woman here is who i've been
focusing in on and her reactions are
maybe the most deranged of anybody owner
refuses to release a list of justices
you know
i uh i was told that
a big thing when i was running last time
nobody really knew me they knew me
very well we had great success at the
apprentice and in business
and it was great but they never knew
what kind of a judge i would pick or
to be a justice right a justice of the
supreme court
and i said well that's i mean what am i
going to do how am i going to solve that
problem but you know i was in politics
never don't forget when i ran they said
no he's inexperienced
you know and i ran against some very
talented people somebody turns out there
was something
very good friends of mine some of whom i
don't like too much
you know when i don't like somebody it
lasts for a long time
but i i said well how do we solve that
problem
i don't know they just weren't believe
you know the the appointment of
a united states supreme court justice
was much more important to the voters
than i thought and they're right
because they will set policy for 50
years
they'll set more we know whether it's
life whether it's
second amendment your second amendment
if i weren't president you know the
pressure
your second amendment would be
obliterated it would maybe be gone
but at a minimum obliterated they
haven't touched your second amendment
not even touched it
he's in power republicans blocking
sports
i'm like alignment for the pittsburgh
steelers
i'm a blocking force no they haven't
touched it
but your second amendment would be
undersea so
nobody knew i never knew you know you
hear about supreme court you know about
supreme court you know about other
judges by the way at the end of
the first term we'll be close to 300
federal judges including court of
appeals
that's a nightmare which i think is a
record i guess it's a record it's a lot
that's a lot nobody's done that and very
important that's a record three
think of that 300 that's a big
percentage of the entire
judiciary think of that 300 and
many many court of appeals judges but
two
great supreme court judges or justices
and
now we're going to get a third uh can
you imagine
can you imagine our enemies three in one
term
so many presidents they just don't have
the chance yeah it's so important but i
i said to my people i said so if they
don't believe me what i'll do is i'll
make up a list of 25 judges
and or people and will tell them i will
only pick from that list
they said that sounds like an
interesting idea this was my idea you
have to be
you know office before you have to have
a little bit of imagination
so i got out on a list i i named the
people the people that i said
and i promise that i will pick someone
like the people on this list
and it didn't work it went nowhere
because they didn't trust it if they
didn't trust they said we want you to
pick the people on the list
not somebody like the people oh my god
so i went back the next week i said
i will pick somebody that's on this list
now they were all
great great uh judges for the most part
i think almost
entirely but judges and really respected
conservative
uh believers in our country solid
incredible people
and as soon as i did that things went
through the roof it was amazing how
important it was
by the way would you stand up with that
beautiful jacket i love that
i love this guy how many times oh no
how many events he's been to a couple
that's really great thank you very much
i've seen him before he's been here a
couple of times like about 90.
thank you man that's really nice i'm
gonna get one of those jackets by the
way and you know the wall
the wall yeah 330 miles
330 miles they got another 30 miles in
the last two days he's been saying 300
this week so far
and yes we have a great relationship
with mexico
and you know they keep saying yes first
they said he'll never be able to build
it because i had the
democrats were just brutal i made a
terrible mistake i said it last night
i should have said we will not under any
circumstances
build a wall at our southern border
they would have given me all the money
in the world
but stupidly i said we will build the
wall trump saying he should be lying
more interesting
but we got we won we won court cases we
won court cases
oh my god in fact i want so much money
we could build four walls if we wanted
yeah
and yet we've still got nothing and they
said all right
all right we've you know they've lost i
mean so by the way we're up to 330
the exact wall their their dream choice
you know i said to the border patrol i
love these people they're great ice
the border patrol what they do is
incredible they're incredible
i said give me your dream wall as long
as we're building it we might as well
build the wall that you want
let's build it right sir we have to have
vision we need steel
and concrete i said how about one or the
other they said no sir we need steel and
concrete
we need steel and inside you know inside
those poles we have rebar
and we have concrete right and they're
30 feet tall
we need all sorts i think we need them
to be wired i mean i won't tell you why
they're wired but they're wired for a
reason
they're all wired up and they're
incredible but you know what
uh we got the wall nobody could have
done it
so once we had the wall and it started
going up and then we hit 100 miles 200
miles
now we're at 3 30 and we're building 10
miles a week
and it'll be finished very soon guys
that math is not checking out that math
is not checking out
in a number of different ways i coming
along
and we've done phenomenally well because
that's a lot of the territory that we
need
we're going to go up to probably a
little bit over 500 miles so we're at 3
30.
but once they saw that i had it they
said
yeah but mexico is not paying for it
okay but they are paying for it mexico
is paying for them they're not
they are paying for it they're paying at
the border they're paying for the wall
you know all those trucks to go back and
forth
they're paying for the wall no so the
democrats said yeah but
they always have to find something right
and you remember what i used to say that
if they fight us remember people would
say what happens
if they fight you on the wall what
happens if they fight you right to hell
on the wall
i said the wall would get 10 feet taller
do you remember that
took a little hit on that we took a
little bit of a hit i'm feeling more and
more confident that this particular
woman right here
may be the most ideologically insane in
uh
in in view of what we see just keep an
eye on her well and it's strong and it's
great
and we appreciate because mexico has
been working with us very closely they
have right now
27 000 mexican soldiers on our southern
border
making sure that people don't come into
our country
i want to thank the president of mexico
very helpful so i made this list of
potential justices and i'll tell you it
all changed now i'm asking sleepy joe
biden to give me a list
and he doesn't want to do it you know
why because he can only put
super radical why would biden give trump
a list it's ridiculous
people that would destroy your country
and he knows that he's not electable he
shouldn't be electable anyway you know i
mean
he's the worst candidate you know where
he is today
they have a thing called the lid lid i
don't even know do you know what lint
stands for
lid he put out a lit you can actually
hear this woman screaming stuff it's
interesting you can pick up a pick up
her voice if you listen carefully
working my ass off i'm in
ohio i'm in texas i'm in florida i'm in
michigan
i'm in wisconsin
[Music]
[Applause]
understand that there's people i mean
presumably there's people here who these
people could be your doctor
these people could be your dentist these
people could be your accountant they
could be teaching your kids
these these are the people screaming and
cheering this seven rallies
saying we love you that's never happened
to a politician before
my apologies i don't want to be a
politician
i don't think of myself as a politician
but it really is i appreciate it
and i don't think i've never heard it i
liked ronald reagan but they never said
we love you maybe they did they're gonna
try and find out
then they'll say president trump lied
last night
because 40 years ago i remember
but no nobody's ever heard that one
before and i appreciate it because
it is reciprocal thank you very much
reciprocal reciprocal
it's reciprocal i had such a nice life
before i did this
i had such a nice life then i had the
witch hunt that goes on forever it goes
on
and then we catch them spying on our
campaign how about that
thank you man let's see what happens
though how many people
in the crowd do you think actually know
what trump's talking about and how many
just cheer
and then the guys that were doing the
investigation they have their
31 different phones they were
accidentally wiped clean
31 different phones i think it was like
19 different people
and they all did the same exact accident
which if you knew anything about phones
it's almost an impossibility
to do it once they believe not alone 31
different times
so we caught him and that's called
obstruction we have to remember
it's called obstruction
lock who up who are they chanting to be
in prison now
that was the mueller group that was a
mula grip all those phones
lock up the former fbi director for
running an investigation the subpoena on
the 33 i said forget about these things
because you'll find them they have them
they're in the same smartest person on
stage is the kid with a face shield
right i mean that's got to be if you you
know
these are pretty it's slim pickings but
that's got to be it
3 000 they have a request from the u.s
congress
right that's not bad u.s congress they
want
they send a subpoena very very important
and after getting the subpoena she
deleted
all of her emails and acid washed and
asked telephones
i've gotten rid of phones too i threw
them away right she took cameras and she
beat that
that can't possibly be true right
hillary's be
using a hammer on cameras come on angry
obviously if she
if she did the hammer work but if anyone
else did this
see there's a protection there's a dual
level of
justice but we're getting down sorry
guys i know face shields aren't
effective i i'm just trying to you know
say something about this kid but yes he
should be wearing a mask
and a face shield and a beekeeper's
outfit and a suit of armor over that
faces that it was all about
her daughter's wedding chelsea and also
yoga classes right right 33
000 emails on yoga and a wedding
i don't think so and comey said oh
that's okay that sounds like a good
reason
that's comey that's another beauty right
there they called it
well we caught him we caught him very
smart move
getting rid of that guy was a smart move
but we caught him
listen we caught him they were spying on
the campaign
they were doing actually worse than that
but there was nobody's ever done
anything like this
so let's see what happens but we caught
him cold we got so much to
remember the ins the insurance policy
right
from strzok and page two lovers
you know they were very smart they would
uh use the public servers
they'd send it over the public wires
because they didn't want to be
caught having an affair so they went
over the public
that was a very good thing for us wasn't
it
darling darling darling please
she's going to win she's going to win
isn't she
peter peter only you can save us
oh man peter she's going to win
this is america yes darling she's going
to win i know
100 000 to nothing
remember that actually
it was actually 100 million to one so
this was a hundred million to one this
is this idiot
so listen what's up darling please
please tell me again
yes 100 million to one she's going to
win
but just in case she doesn't
we have an insurance policy now that
only means one thing
and we went through the insurance policy
and we caught them
so let's see what happens to these
treasonous crooks
these terrible people and they put our
nation through
turmoil but i just want to thank a lot
of people were very unfairly treated
you look at general flynn look he's
still going through it can you believe
it
but a lot of people were unfairly
treated
by a bunch of treasonous horrible
people and they used the intelligence
agencies of our country
to try and steal an election and to try
and do a coup
when you think i mean who would ever
think this country but that's all you
can say i mean some people would say
well that's a conspiracy theory no
just take a look at the records so i i
just it's just a very exciting for me
it's a very exciting thing
because what's exciting something that
nobody would have thought possible now
let's see what happens but we have them
called
they spied on our campaign it's our
campaign
right flynn pled guilty americans
you have to go out get out and vote this
is the most
important election in just three and a
half years
we've secured america's borders which
makes them very unhappy
rebuilt the awesome power of the u.s
military
we built the military it was totally
depleted when i took over
wrong we built a military two and a half
trillion dollars we spent all made in
the usa the greatest equipment the
greatest planes and rockets and missiles
rockets and our nuclear i hate to even
mention the word but
and hope to god we never have to use it
but we have the most powerful
weapons in the history of the world
and we did that over a very short period
of time
weapons that are so powerful
that we're the envy of the world but i
never want to use those weapons and
hopefully we'll never have to you know
the way you don't have to use them is
when you have them
it's when you have them but nobody's
ever built the force like what we have
and you know the uh the newspapers and
the press
and the fake news they went and said he
just gave away classified information
said no i will look you right in the eye
let me tell first of all i'm allowed to
do it i'm the president so i'm allowed
i'm the one i'm the only one that's
allowed imagine cheering for that
no no i didn't give away i'm just
telling you most powerful
weapons ever produced we have
and other countries know that and it's a
good thing that they know it
and i don't think we'll ever be using
them and i hope we
don't i hope to god i use the word god
because they refuse to use the word god
yeah biden's religious trump's not
allegiance i don't i don't even want a
religious president just pointing it out
we never have to use them
but i obliterated the isis caliphate
which was all over the place 100
remember i got it down to 99 they said
you got to go 100 i said let's get out
of here
we're bringing them all back home
everyone's coming back home
so he didn't obliterate it long wars
the never-ending wars right the endless
wars
we fixed our disastrous trade deals they
were a disaster
brought jobs and factories back to
pennsylvania
under 16 years and think of this
16 think of this for 16 years presidents
obama president bush household income
rose
2000 nine hundred and forty five dollars
right that's over
a sixteen year period in three years
your household income rose almost ten
thousand dollars when you include energy
you have to include energy
i don't know what he means by when you
include energy but
that is certainly not true dollars but
we have to include energy i mean how
much are you paying for your gasoline
you never saw two dollar gasoline you're
less right it's less
they go up it's less now it's uh it's
a big difference what is it nowadays
come on tell me i haven't got any guess
i haven't stopped recently at a gas
station i'm
15.
what the hell is he talking about years
we lifted
6.6 million people out of poverty the
largest poverty reduction in the history
of our country
guys i i mean i haven't got i haven't
gotten gas for a while either i've had
i've had
an electric car for a while but 15 what
make america great again and now i'm
going to say this make america great
again again
[Music]
make america great again again
we saved 1.4 million jobs in
pennsylvania alone
and to fight the china virus it's the
china virus not the coronavirus
corona sounds like a place in italy a
beautiful place it's corona
no it's the china virus they don't want
to say it you know the radical left they
don't want to say it
do you ever notice they're always going
after russia look uh-oh nobody's been
tougher in russia than me but jesus
russia russia russia i said what about
china
they didn't want to mention it you know
they got little deals going on i think
little but coronavirus doesn't it sound
like
italy a beautiful villa you have a
beautiful corona
now it's a china virus i should have
stopped it to fight the china virus we
launched the largest
national mobilization since world war ii
we did an incredible we did an a
plus job except we did a d job
in terms of public relations explaining
it because we were too busy doing it
but the fact that no they were doing a
bad job at explaining it
and they were doing a bad job at doing
it yeah they were they was bad all
around can't talk about anything so it
gets up
uh the uh the coronavirus
they say we want to talk about supreme
court judges today
well i don't know about that the
coronavirus
and he doesn't know we did a great job
he has no two he said i should have
opened
no he goes i should have shut down one
week earlier
what he doesn't say is he did the worst
job in the history of
an epidemic or a pandemic with the swine
flu
it was a joke and what he did what he
did
his own man that was in charge said
recently
we had no idea what the hell we were
doing it was a total disaster
there were amateurs and i challenge
anyone to tell me what he's talking
about right now i mean i know like
generally he's talking about coronavirus
but what point is he making
except when it came to closing the
border which i did
which turned out to save tens of
thousands of lives
biden criticized me until two months
later when he said i was right
but we should have closed a weaker think
of that we pioneered life-saving
therapies
reducing the fatality rate 85 percent
since
april think of that remdesseviere
the plasma we have among the lowest case
fatality rates of any major currency
people are getting people who drop
people are getting
banned so quickly in both youtube and um
twitch chat right now it's unbelievable
what's going on europe is doing better
actually we did better
but now europe has a big spike a big
spike
so they're not talking about that the
number of hospitalized virus patients is
down by
47 percent and virus patients coming to
the emergency room
is down and visits our way down visits
the hospital
europe is almost a 50 greater excess
mortality rate
than the united states so you know
they're likely to compare us to europe
50 percent greater excess mortality rate
our early and aggressive actions save
millions of lives through operation
warp speed you've heard about it they
don't want to talk about it what we've
done
in a record period of time with the
ventilators and we're
creating now we're building ventilators
for the world very hard to do
right we'll develop and distribute a
vaccine very very shortly in record time
it would have been two or three years
four years
if biden's group had done it but we've
done a great job with the fda
and clearing a path and you'll be seeing
it very shortly and these are great
companies that are building
so we'll crush the virus and our
opponents will
with him they will crush america we
can't let it happen
this country is too great our love of
each other is too great
this guy doesn't know he's alive i mean
he really doesn't
he doesn't know he's alive you know
you'll notice now is when the crowd kind
of starts getting sleepier and often
they'll tune out until
trump starts his wrap-up crescendo i've
said before not that i
now that he needs to take my advice and
why would he but
these are these are too long really they
really are and people start
zoning out and he's ranting and raving
if if i think he would get more out of
it
from making these a little more punchy i
don't know he's going to get something
he'll be
you know because i watched him so badly
he performed so badly in the debates and
then
with bernie he was average not great but
he got through
and i said what the hell is he taking
and we'd like to ask him and i said that
we want a drug test here's the drug
stuff
because with bernie he was able to get
through but listen i mean
it wasn't winston churchill this wasn't
the greatest debate but he got through
it was fine
him and bernie screaming at each other
mostly burning crazy burning he's not
too happy
i'll tell you did you ever see a better
loser than bernie seriously he's a good
loser he
he got terribly treated by hillary and
that group
and then it happened again with
elizabeth warren right it happened again
what the democrat party did to him and
then you have this guy mike bloomberg
mini mike
one question he was gone there goes 1.8
billion
i said you think it's easy up here mike
don't you was that when elizabeth warren
used the term horse-faced lesbians that
trump's referring to
mini mike maymont
so now he's trying to buy into the party
you would think after the way they
treated him they called him every name
pocahontas destroyed him she didn't do
good against me but boy did she do good
against minnie mike and
instead of i figured he'd be calling and
saying listen i want to become a
republican
you know we've done great for the
economy you'd think right
but he always wanted to run for
president and he tried before i guess
but he tried and it was a bad experience
and you would think he would have joined
our party
but instead he's trying to buy his way
back in when somebody treats you that
way
even stay neutral don't go back in he
wants to give them a lot of money to try
and buy their friendship
and you know one thing you learned about
politics i spent
a fraction of the money that crooked
hillary spent they raised two billion
dollars i've
spent i spent my own money but i spent a
fraction of the money
like 35 30
and we won nobody ever says that it's
not about money
it's about other things there are other
things involved it's not just about
money
yeah it's about narcissism you know in
the old days
my father would teach me if you can win
and spend less that's a good thing
and i remember after i won and i won
decisively look
306 to 223 that's a lot
306 delegates 306
that's decisive we won michigan and
we're going to win it again we're up in
a poll just now oh they're going crazy
they're going crazy we won wisconsin we
won pennsylvania
but my father taught me he said if you
can win and spend less money that's a
good thing not a bad thing
that's a good thing not a bad thing like
if you get along with
the leaders of other lands and don't go
to war all the time with everybody
and can come out on top without having
to shed blood all over the place and
destroy your families and your country
like when i get along with putin when i
get along with kim jong-un whatever
happened to the war we were supposed to
be in with north korea nothing happened
he tried to start i gave away so much i
said people talked about it
they couldn't find anything i didn't do
anything they said you met oh i met oh
okay that's
i meant now you would have been in war
with her you would have been well but if
you can spend think of this
if you can spend less money and win
that's the right thing
so after i won one of these people back
there right back there
in order to keep the thing going on
trump i had one
he said but trump raised substantially
less money than crooked hillary clinton
that's because i didn't need the money i
didn't need
and i can call up a lot of rich guys and
raise a lot of money but i feel
uncomfortable doing it because when you
do that it's like you're sort of it's
not the same
i could call up every guy they call me
up and they say
sir how are you sir mr president sir
i don't have too many friends up because
we know i used to be comfortable you
have to be comfortable with people right
and i have friends i have one friend
richard i talk about them all the time
but they're
multiply this times 100 people richard
richard used to call me up five six
years ago hey let's have dinner
all right where do you want to go i
don't know go to some crazy wrestling
today the restaurants are all closed in
new york they don't want to open them
they want to make them do badly it's a
dream of course don't worry they're
opening on november 4th
but it's true so it's richard on the
phone richard my friend for many many
years
and i said hey rich i don't mr president
sir how are you i said well
he's been calling me donny and don and
dj
and all richard are you okay everything
good
uh yes sir mr president sir you're doing
a great job and
i'd like to thank you good richard
richard listen up please you don't have
to call me mr president
i said so just call me donald it's okay
thank you donald i really appreciate it
and you hear the guy he can't breathe
you know he's having a hard time
breathing
why are you nervous and then at the end
of the phone he goes mr president again
thank you so much for the job you do
hangs up i said
how can you be friends with you know it
just doesn't work
wow it seems like being president has
been terrible for trump's personal life
called respect for the office they have
respect for the office they really do
nothing wrong with it sort of understand
it
they have respect for the cautious
cheering from the audience
this office is that i do and that's why
i'm doing a great job and i'll always do
a great job
disrespectfully
but on november 3rd pennsylvania will
decide
whether we end the pandemic defeat the
virus and return to
record prosperity just like we were
before
or whether we allow sleepy joe biden
who doesn't have a clue could we be
lucky enough that he's actually going
into the crescendo now
pay the vaccine yes sir
he wants to impose a four trillion
dollar tax hike you believe what tell
you
ban american energy which means what and
let's go back
let's call up the middle east and let's
be real nice to them because we need
their enemies call the middle east
destroy your suburbs you know i got rid
of this regulation that was going to
destroy your suburbs
destroy your suburbs the obama i call it
the obama regulation
right they build nice projects right
next to your beautiful home lots of luck
give free healthcare i hope the people
in the suburbs yours when i did this i
took a lot of heat
i got rid of a regulation they all said
sir we'll amend the regulation we're
going to amend it
i said i don't want to re amend it and a
couple of stories were
i wish the women living in the suburbs
would read these stories
they were they were written by people
that say
i can't believe a president had the guts
to do it
i did because i want to save the
american dream and by the way
a big part of the american dream are
minorities who made it and they want to
live in the suburbs
and they don't want to be next to a
project what i thought trump wanted to
keep the minorities out of the suburbs i
thought that was the whole coded message
here
say i don't know i'm making up my mind
and corey booker
was the one that was going to lead it
out he was going to be the one he wants
it to be wants those
projects to be nice and big and i just
hope you
i just hope you're going to remember
that
sooner than november 3rd because you can
do it sooner
give free health care to illegally so
the problem with free healthcare we all
have a heart
we all want to take care of people the
problem is when you promise free
education free health care
all this stuff but free health care
remember sleepy joe during the debate
who wants to get well it's not free it's
that as a country we say let's
fund these programs through taxation
this idea of free
is yet another one of these canards that
they love
sleepy joe and he'll do it because he
has no choice because they have total
power he's like a puppet for them
and indoctrinate your children with
poisonous anti-american lies
to combat the toxic left-wing propaganda
in our schools
i announced last week that we are
launching a new pro-american lesson plan
for students called
1776 commission
imagine cheering for that
we will teach our children the truth
about america
that we are the most exceptional nation
on the face of the earth and getting
better every single day we're not going
to let it fail
the democrat party has joined forces
with flag burners
anarchists anti-police people they're
extremists
[Music]
agitators and then they say oh no no
this is a peaceful
this was a peaceful protest this is a
peaceful protest
[Music]
they know what i'm talking about they
know our great uniform
brilliant we love them but you know what
we call it a peaceful protest now
because
the only thing you're allowed to do in
pennsylvania you can't go to church all
right guys uh
i'm getting to the end of my time and it
seems like people are starting to trail
off we've gotten a good sense of what
we're seeing from donald trump today
so i'm going to be with you guys again
very soon i believe we might be actually
having a press
briefing tomorrow and if that's the case
i am going to be here with you thank you
so much for joining me thanks for
everybody who supported if you really
think that watching more of this is good
for you
there will certainly be other channels
continuing to carry it i'll see
everybody tomorrow
you